ce qui est très dangereux c'est que il
ya tellement de menaces de mort
aujourd'hui tout le monde en reçoit
qu'elles sont un tout petit peu
maintenant un peu banalisé comme si
c'étaient les assurés alors que ça ne
doit pas être banalisé et que je touche
du bois mais un jour ça pourra finir mal
ces histoires et oui bien sûr quand j'ai
vu les positions sur les gilets jaunes
ou même sur bilal assez n'y a pas très
longtemps la violence que ça crée est
hallucinante et oui ça change la vie seb
est ce que je vous dis à mes choristes
en voiture et qui a ça m'est arrivé à
tmax à scooter avec deux casques avait
juste à côté de vous et les deux vous
regarde vous ai vraiment de panique
quand je rentre dans un parking
maintenant j'attends tout le temps que
la porte se ferme derrière pas de sûr
que personne ne rentre oui vous vivez
dans une espèce de terreur qui avant
n'existait pas du tout du tout parce que
je sais que les carottes dans le parking
c'est le but guy mollet sont naturels
pardon chez les buts des ménages de te
mettre dans un état exactement et on vit
différemment on regarde dans le rétro on
regarde derrière on vit tout le temps
comme si on était à l'antenne vous avez
changé de comportement pas à quoi à
l'antenne vous hésité à dire des choses
maintenant oui mais on est en direct
j'hésite j'essaie de moins remporter
j'essaie de 2 oui bien sûr parce que il
parfois vous avez envie de parler sur
des sujets vous dit non je vais pas y
aller oui absolument vraiment absolument
oui toute la première partie d'émission
j'adore cette émission déconne avec vous
et tout ça après des débats sociétaux et
après c'est vrai que quand sept des neuf
armes à feu très chaud je me dis d'abord
réfléchi bien est-ce que tel niveau et
surtout encore une fois aujourd'hui
pardon je parle avec eux très franchise
j'ai beaucoup de lâcheté et pardon je me
dis est ce que ça va valoir ce que je
veux dire la la peine derrière d'avoir
une semaine de de peur ne peuvent
vraiment pour moi les autres alors
parfois je reconnais que je fais pas
preuve d'un grand courage
et toujours aux bornes on a discuté et
de ces temps ci vient d'expliquer un
jour on dira pas le sujet et aux
téléspectateurs il est venu voir un jour
dans ma loge il est resté très longtemps
ouais il parlait pas non il était sur le
so far away et
il me le dira mon âge étaient en larmes
il est en larmes jure que c'est vrai il
me dit je crois que juge j'aurais pas dû
revenir exactement c'est vrai c'est vrai
lundi matin et jour je vais parler je ne
j'ai dit ce que je pensais de
voilà ce qu'il me disait j'ai qui me
disait c'est trop de pression c'est trop
de j'ai trop peur je vais pas réagir
surtout les débats
on en a discuté pendant une heure une
heure et demi ensemble absolument ray le
soir c'était un jeu plein vendredi ou
quoi le sort tu m'as envoyé un texto à
22 heures j'étais tout seul chez moi tu
es très mignon qui m'a beaucoup touché
mais oui c'est vrai que que que j'ai
peur souvent souvent mais j'ai peur pour
beaucoup de choses mais depuis je fais
cette émission remparts dont ses pairs
sur plein de sujets sûr sûr sûr je
rappelle quand même que je me suis fait
casser ma voiture deux fois entièrement
cassé dans un parking alors qu'ils
avaient les mercedes des machins j'avais
juste une smart que je me suis fait
sortir d'un taxi que je me suis fait
poursuivre dans la rue bien sûr j'ai
peur j'ai pas été dit que comme ça je
vais pas me battre c'est pas machin dans
leur maintenant dans la faim je suis pas
comme je ne sais pas me battre et tout
ça va parfois je préfère fermer ma
gueule plutôt que c'est pas très grand
je vous dis ah mais non mais
c'est plus grand que ceux qui vont
menacer
de le dire je vous dis c'est vrai